اشخاص بدت عليهم علامات الجوع
والمسغبه يلاحقون القوافل بحثا عن عما
يقيم اودهم حتى اولئك الاشخاص الذين اذا
ما تمكن اولئك من العوده الى منازلهم فما
من منزل ليعودوا
اليه سيدي
الرئيس كما قلت في
السابق في اجتماعات سابقه ان المساعده
الانسانيه في جميع انحاء غزه باتت شبه
مستحيله ان وصولنا الى خان يونس والمنطقه
الوسطى
بات مستحيلا اما في الجنوب فان اتساع نطاق
العمليات
الهجوميه في
رفح والتي باتت تنال بالفعل من العمليات
الانسانيه المرهقه والتي تحتاج الى تدابير
استثنائيه لايصال ما تيسر من المساعدات
الشحيحه
اصلا ولكنها تشهد على جساره اولئك الذين
يضحون
بارواحهم من اجل ايصال هذه المساعدات
وفيما راينا بعد الزياده ربما الطفيفه في
اعداد الناقلات والشاحنات التي تدخل عبر
معبر رفح وكرم شلوم
فان الامدادات الانسانيه بمفردها لن تتمكن
من اقامه اود اكثر من مليوني
نسمه قلنا ذلك في السابق وقال الامين
العام ذلك في السابق لا يمكن ابدا ان نحل
محل القطاع التجاري في غزه القطاع الخاص
في غزه الذي يقط عليه اكثر من 80% الم من
سكان غزه الذين يعولون عليه من اجل اقامه
حياتهم العاديه اليوميه ان السلع التجاريه
ينبغي ان يسمح بدخولها بكميات
كبيره وهي في الحقيقه ينبغي ان تاخذ
اولويه على المساعدات
وكما قلت في السابق فثم قائمه متنا
متناميه وتزداد هذه القائمه وتطول بالمواد
الممنوعه والمرفوض كل هذا في الحقيقه يجعل
من المستحيل او يعجزنا عن ايصال المساعدات
المهمه الى غزه لاعاده ترميم البنا
التحتيه التي تقيم الحياه ان نظام الاجلاء
الطبي ايضا للمرضى الى مصر بات غير كاف
بشكل مروع سيدي الرئيس في هذه الظروف ومع
انتشار العمليات العدائيه باتجاه الجنوب
مع زياده في الضغط الذي يفضي الى النزوح
الجماعي للناس ال الى بلدان مجاوره هذه
مساله جد
خطيره بعض البلدان قد عرضت بالفعل ان
تستضيف مدنيين الذين يرغبون في مغادره غزه
لحمايتهم واود في هذا الصدد وبعد
اذنكم ان اؤكد على ان اي
اشخاص هجروا من غزه ينبغي ان يسمح لهم
بالعوده ذلك بموجب القانون الدولي وفي هذا
السياق فاننا
نحذر و وفي الحقيقه نشعر بالتهديد بسبب
البيانات الاخيره التي صدرت عن بعض
الوزراء الاسرائيليين فيما يتعلق بخطط
تشجع على الترانسفير او النقل الجماعي
للمدنيين من غزه الى بلدان اخرى وفيما
يعرف الان بفولت يشن او النقل الطوعي هذه
البيانات بالمناسبه تثير حفيظتها وت ثير
حفيظه الكثيرين والانشغالات ايضا
بامكانيه النزوح القصري ربما او الترحيل
القصري لسكان الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه وهي
مساله يحضرها القانون الدولي واي محاوله
لتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في غزه
ينبغي ان ترفض
رفضا كاملا شكلا وموضوعا سيدي الرئيس ان
غزه فيما هي مركز هذه الازمه فدعونا لا
ننسى ولن ننسى ابدا ولا ينبغي ان ننسى 12
شخص قد قتلوا الاف جرحوا ومئات قد اخذوا
واختطفوا في الهجمات الوحشيه التي شنتها
حماس وجماعات مسلحه اخرى على اسرائيل في
السابع من اكتوبر تلك التي رايتها ورايتها
انتم وراها
الكثيرون راينا وهذا بالاضافه الى
الروايات التي تردد عن العنف الجنسيه
المروع والمقيت اما اطلاق الصواريخ فهو
يجري بلا هواده في المناطق الماهوله
بالسكان في اسرائيل مما يتسبب في المزيد
من الخسائر المدنيه والرخ والكرب والصدمات
اسر وذو الرهائن ينتظرون الافراج عن
احبائهم منذ اكثر من 100 يوم
يتحسسون اخبارا عن
سلامتهم
[موسيقى]
للاسف منذ نوفمبر لم يطلق سراح اي رهائن
ولم تردنا اي
معلومات او حتى لم ترد اسرهم وذويهم
واحبائه اي معلومات اكثر من 100 الف نسمه
قد
نزحوا داخل
اسرائيل وينبغي ان ننسى ذلك ينبغي انلا
ننسى ايض اثر هذه الحرب على اسرائيل اذ
نزح اكث اكثر من 100 ال نسمه نتيجه لهجمات
السابع من اكتوبر التي شنتها حماس وجماعات
مسلحه اخرى ونظرا ايضا وبسبب الصواريخ
التي تطلق من جانب الجماعات المسلحه في
غزه
ولبنان وانا منشغل ايام انشغال بسبب
او اذاء خطر امكانيه الانتشار الاقليميه
لهذا النزاع
لقد راينا تزايد في حالات التوتر والاعمال
العدائيه في الضفه الغربيه ا اننا ايضا
نجد ان وذلك مع استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه على البلدات الفلسطينيه
والزيادات المنذره بالخطر في معدلات عنف
المستوطنين مما يفضي الى الموت وتشرد وهدم
المنازل وجميعنا يعلم تماما زياده التوتر
والنشاط العسكري في لبنان وفي البحر
الاحمر وفي اليمن في الحقيقه ينبغي ان
نسمح بانتشار هذا النزاع وباتساع رقعته
وان تتولد عنه عواقب تنذر بانفجار اوسع لا
يمكن ان نتخيله سيدي الرئيس ما رايناه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر هو
وصمه على ضميرنا
المشترك وعلى ضمير كل من يستمع الى هذه
الكلمات وما لم نتصرف فان هذه المساله
ستتفاقم
ستصبح درنا
ووصمه لا يمكن محوها ابدا من جبين البشريه
اولئك ثم من
يقضون نحبهم ومن يعانون من الصواريخ
والقنابل والقذائف
والرصاص باعداد هذا الى جانب الاعداد
المتزايده من الذين
يقضون ويذهبون ضحايا للجوع والتجويع
والمرض
والتعرض
للخطر هذا بالاضافه الى اثار الجراح التي
اثخن بها شعب غزه لا يمكن ان نسمح لذلك
بالاستمرار وبالطبع فانا اكرر ندائي من
اجل الامتثال للقانون الدولي الانساني بما
في ذلك المدنيين والبناء التحتيه التي
يعتمدون عليها وايصال اساسيات البقاء
وتيسير المساعدات الانسانيه على النطاق
المطلوب
والمعامله الانسانيه والافراج الفوري عن
كل الرهاءن
[موسيقى]
و كما اشرت ربما في يوم سابق او في امسيه
سابقه فانني اكرر ندائي بضروره وقف اطلاق
النار وانا اكر من جديد ندائي لهذا المجلس
باتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لانهاء هذه
الحرب شكرا جزيلا لحسن
الاستماع